david vaani effective immediately  transgender individuals will be able to  openly serve in the US Armed Forces  defense secretary ash Carter says  service members may not be involuntarily  separated discharged or denied based on  gender identity our mission is to defend  this country and we don't want barriers  unrelated to a person's qualification to  serve preventing us from recruiting or  retaining the soldier sailor Airman  marine who can best accomplish the  mission we have to have access to a  hundred percent of america's population  for our all-volunteer force to be able  to recruit from among them the most  highly qualified the full policy must be  implemented by July of 2017